mortgage rates were at a historic low
just a few months ago but the federal
reserve they stepped in they said that
they were going to destroy demand and
they began to aggressively raise
interest rates as you would expect
mortgage rates have skyrocketed over the
last nine months and now we sit with the
highest mortgage rates that we've seen
since the 2008 housing crisis this has
led to a significant cooldown in the
amount of people who want to borrow
capital to go and purchase homes
interest rates have now closed in
hitting almost six percent for the u.s
mortgage market but not all mortgage
interest rates are created equally as we
can see here charlie bolillo points out
that the adjustable rate mortgage in the
us has moved up to 4.6 percent which is
the highest since 2009. just at the end
of last year it was down under 2.5
and the 15-year mortgage rate in the us
has risen to over 5
which is the highest level since 2008
and just a year ago it was down around
two percent
last but not least the monthly mortgage
payment on the median home for sale in
the united states has increased 40
percent over the last year it's now up
over three hundred dollars as mortgage
rates have moved from two point eight
eight percent to just under six percent
now of course we should expect the
federal reserve to have an impact in the
market they are intervening they are
trying to destroy demand and a great way
to destroy demand is to make capital
more expensive that's exactly what
they've done
inflation has not necessarily come down
in the way that they would have expected
but we do know that they are
successfully destroying that demand what
this leads to is a stagflationary period
it's quite scary we right now have high
inflation and we're in a recession with
two consecutive quarters of negative gdp
growth the big question remains can they
continue to raise interest rates while
we're in a recession this is quite
unprecedented times regardless of what
happens to the overall economy or gdp
growth one thing to continue to watch
how high will the u.s mortgage rates go
as the federal reserve remains committed
to raising the interest rate and the
cost of capital i don't know but what i
do know is that they already have an
impact if they continue to raise those
interest rates and mortgage rates
continue to spike they're likely to lead
to some sort of pain in the housing
market nobody wants that u.s mortgage
rates are now at a high that we haven't
seen since 2008 14 years ago
i hope that the federal reserve can get
inflation under control it can return
back to that loose monetary policy and
bring some normalization back to the
market so that the average american
family can not only buy a home but they
also have all sorts of freedom because
they have extra cash flow that isn't
being eroded away by inflation and also
isn't being spent on all of these
consumer products that continue to
increase significantly in price hey you
did you like this video great make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time